[Applause]
[Music]
for once the predictions became true
french president emmanuel macron not
only won but crushed his rival marianne
le pen in the second round of the french
presidential election we are talking
about no less than 16 points of
difference approximately 58 percent from
macron and 42 for le pen yes the margin
was smaller than the previous
presidential elections in which these
two politicians also faced each other
and in which the difference was 32
points but we are still talking about a
huge difference in a country where
re-election is not exactly common
macron's victory marks the first time in
20 years that a french president has won
a second term and the first in more than
50 years that he has done so by
completely dominating political life
without having to work with a government
and a prime minister of a different
party elected by the national assembly
the first time in more than 50 years
you can't deny that it's all a bit
political even more so if we take into
account that the re-election has taken
place after a pandemic a crisis and in
the midst of a huge inflationary spiral
and on top of that the absence rate was
enormous and what can i say when you
want to change or prefer the alternative
you do not stay at home in other words
we can almost speak of a new sun king
for french politics he is not the most
beloved leader and has a reputation for
authoritarianism but he has command in
term and yes the most shocking thing of
all is that the french are not
particularly fond of him in opinion
polls he is regularly accused of being
arrogant authoritarian and snobbish i'm
sure photos like this one probably don't
help
and not only that we can't even say that
his political proposals seem to dazzle
the masses
in the first round almost 60 percent of
french voters supported the extreme
right or extreme left candidates in fact
his victory was accompanied by an
abstention rate of 28 points also the
highest and half a century in the second
round it is clear that macron does not
arouse passions but then why has macron
made a clean sweep where is french
politics headed and what can we expect
in his new term at the helm of france
well let's take a look
[Music]
why macron
[Music]
the french leader has managed france
with a firm hand in 2017 he came to
power under a banner of neither right
nor left just himself trying to shape a
new france throughout his first term
there were times when his presidency
seemed closed to the end yet he always
bounced back again and again take for
example the case of the yellow vests the
largest protests in decades or even the
covet 19 crisis where at the beginning
the friends were among the most opposed
to vaccines today 78 of the population
is fully vaccinated a higher percentage
than in germany the united kingdom or
the united states but above all he has
tried to modernize france and when we
talk about modernizing the gaelic
country we are talking about its economy
to give you an idea france's economy has
grown an average of one percent over the
past 10 years and if instead of looking
at the economy as a whole we look at gdp
per capita well i think a picture here
is worth a thousand words pay attention
to this chart
in international dollars the french have
been losing wealth for more than 14
years and even if we eliminate the
effect of exchange rates and price
variations the result is not much better
the output of the french economy barely
increased by six percent in the entire
decade prior to the pandemic this is a
much worse record than that of most
developed countries
in other words as you can see the french
economy has been practically in a coma
if we were to describe its figures over
the last decade even being generous we
would say that they are disappointing we
are talking about a deficit of more than
six percent of gdp a public debt of more
than 112 an exorbitant public
expenditure of no less than 55 of gdp
and practically no growth in recent
years it is difficult to find any
statistic where things are going really
well in fact it occurs to me that a good
indicator might be industrial production
which in developed countries is an
all-time high and france has
traditionally been a very industrial
country so the question is how has
france's industrial production evolved
well once again i think a picture is
worth a thousand words
in order to address this macron has made
efforts to deregulate the economy and
reduce taxes efforts that have been very
well received by the business community
and have for example made it possible
for unemployment to fall to seven
percent the lowest level since 2008. his
achievements also include the fact that
france is having the fastest post
covered 19 recovery of the major
european economies in fact as you can
see in this chart it was the only major
economy to have recovered to its
pre-pandemic level by the end of 2021
among his first measures after being
sworn in as president in 2017 was to
abolish the wealth tax and among his
greatest achievements the reduction of
eight points in the corporate tax rate
along with the labour reform facility
hiring and firing are unusually
highlighted perhaps this is why it is
not surprising that according to polls
almost 8 out of 10 business executives
voted for the french president but in
any case we're talking about small
changes at least much smaller than what
the french economy really needs but they
have worked for the time being and that
is the line of work he has now pledged
to follow among his promises are to
reduce production taxes for companies
and the self-employed by seven billion
euros cut inheritance tax and achieve a
deficit of three percent of gdp by 2027.
in other words discrete adjustments and
five more years of wild spending
[Music]
since the start of the war in ukraine
alone the french government has spent 22
billion euros that's 23.5 billion us
dollars to compensate consumers and
businesses for gas electricity and
gasoline increases all coming out of the
public coffers and indeed estimates
suggest that mccron's promises far from
stemming the bleeding will add 44
billion euros annually to the french
government deficits if he keeps his
promises that is whatever the case what
is expected is a much more aggressive
international role macron wants to put
paris in the driver's seat in brussels
for instance in recent months we have
seen how he has wanted to play a very
very key role in the ukrainian crisis
even if it has not worked out
particularly well how could good old
emmanuel think that he would not be able
to make vladimir putin see reason as it
stands it's now taken for granted that
the french government will support
europe establishing an oil embargo on
russia but do you know what the ukraine
crisis has shown as one of the most
volatile and fickle parts of his
character this is perhaps the worst side
of the french president the eternal
opportunism of paris check this out
[Music]
the most opportunistic aspect of the
french president
[Music]
over and above everything else
visualpolitik fans macron has been a
lucky guy with enough agility to move
his ships off course when the wind was
blowing in a different direction than
the one he wanted to travel in the last
example was the russian invasion of
ukraine or rather during the run-up to
the invasion as we told you in our
weekly patreon bulletin and also in a
past video here on the channel macron
wanted to take advantage of the tension
on the ukrainian border to gain some
distance from washington claim a
european position of his own and
negotiate with putin whilst also taking
revenge for the affront suffered with
occus when the australian government
cancelled a multi-million dollar
submarine contract with the french
military industry in order to make a
deal with the united states and the
united kingdom and that was not the
worst thing the worst thing is that
paris basically found out about it from
the press there see how little is left
of france's influence
[Music]
at the time the french president said
things like this
europeans must stop being naive we have
to respond and show that we have the
strength and the capacity to defend
ourselves emmanuel macron so when things
in ukraine got red hot macron saw the
perfect opportunity to kick the us
government in the teeth that's why in
the european parliament itself he came
out with this
it is good for the europeans and the
united states to coordinate but it is
necessary for the europeans to conduct
their own dialogue emmanuel macron
presidents of france to the european
parliament no common position no
reinforcement of nato or anything like
that the european union had to go it
alone to negotiate with putin of course
it convinced no one while paris called
for european unity warsaw tallinn riga
vilnius prague stockholm helsinki
copenhagen bratislava virtually all
europe's capitals began to look to
washington and nato it was the best
possible protection the only possible
protection and to top it all off then
came the invasion itself it was clear
that a military response was the only
viable one and there nato wins by a
landslide macron's plan went out the
window
[Music]
and you know what he did next he quickly
did a 180 degree turn a turn that has in
a certain way also played a leading role
during his campaign of the second round
when he adopted some positions of the
left such as the slowing down the
increase of the retirement age or
turning to the greens exactly the
opposite of what his own economic
diagnosis indicates
macron waters down key pension reform in
a bid to woo the left evidently power is
power and france is france we are not
going to blame it for its own nature nor
expect pairs from an oak tree the
problem is that these questions reflect
the major shortcomings of the french
president macron has contributed to
improving france but he's not brought
about the radical change he promised nor
does he seem ready to do so now macron's
victory means continuity in economic
policy and also in foreign policy and
yes at this point i'm going to make a
personal statement although the results
so far have been rather poor it seems
clear that he was by far the best option
and i'm not only talking about marianne
le pen though that is a lot of it the
truth is that we could almost say that
the french politics as a whole is
[Music]
adrift politics of extremes
[Music]
pay attention to these statements
as soon as the russian ukrainian war is
over and settled by a peace treaty i
will call for the implementation of a
strategic reproachment between nato and
russia it is in the interests of france
and europe as well as of the united
states marine le pen
that's a statement that is better
understood when we take into account
this other promise
le pen promises to pull france out of
nato allied command if she wins
presidential election huh how would that
work we wonder le pen continues to see
france as a world superpower a
superpower that has to reclaim its place
in the world and to do so she sees
nothing better than to rebel against
nato and the european union in favor of
pushing for protectionist policies to
get closer to moscow and to juggle
economically because le pen promised big
tax cuts but also big spending increases
and what can i say that is not usually a
good combination it smells more like
populism than anything else like when
she says she wants to fight inflation by
punishing international trade and
lowering vat which would boost household
demand even more and with it prices
well you know how everything looks good
on paper to give you an idea it has been
quantified that le pen's promises would
mean an additional deficit of 105
billion dollars to reach a total hole of
226 billion dollars per year now you
know how to make france great france's
debt that is
[Music]
among her proposals we also found things
like re-establishing the wealth tax
nationalizing the freeway network
lowering the retirement age to 60 and
paying families up to 100 000 euros in
exchange for having at least three
children visualpolitik fans during the
18th century this country gave the world
concepts of left and right now it is
also leading a new transition of
political camps that the analyst gideon
rackman describes as nationalists versus
internationalists between those who fear
globalization and those who embrace it
as an opportunity
there is no more left or right the real
division is between the patriots and the
globalists marine le pen of course that
is limiting and oversimplifying the
political spectrum be that as it may
despite the result the extreme right of
le pen and company is stronger than ever
and indeed it was ahead amongst the
young and the working class nationalism
euroscepticism and rejection of
immigration are gaining more and more
followers
[Music]
and on the left pretty much the same
story the fact that the leader of the
left block is a candidate as radical as
melancholy does not inspire much
confidence either french society seems
increasingly divided and polarized and
if things continue to go from bad to
worse in france the outcome may soon be
very different in the first round of
these elections the historic centre-left
was left with two percent of the votes
and the centre-right did not reach a
meager five percent the political
spectrum was divided between macron's
center and the extremes
macron's biggest challenge will be to
create a sense of cohesion in an
extremely fragmented country tara varma
european council on foreign relations
but at least for now there are five
years of continuity
[Music]
this is precisely why the re-election of
the french president has been greeted
with loud cheers by virtually all
international leaders from biden to
zelinski himself to the president of the
european commission ursula van der
leyden congratulations to emmanuel
macron on his re-election france is our
oldest ally and a key partner in
addressing global challenges i look
forward to our continued close club
operation including on supporting
ukraine defending democracy and
countering climate change be that as it
may a new battle is now brewing what is
known as the third round macron needs to
win the june national assembly elections
to be able to rule as he pleases and
what can i say given what we have seen
let's hope he succeeds macron is not
proving to be a revolutionary president
but at least he has managed to turn the
rusty rudder of french politics yes it
may not be enough but something is
something and amongst the alternatives
there seems to be nothing but old
formulas that are more reminiscent of
the old populist messages of latin
america than the more prosperous
countries it's clear that france needs
many changes economy pensions security
in any case what was surprising were the
results of the elections in the french
overseas territories they were
completely different from those of the
metropolis in the parts of france that
are scattered far away from paris marion
le pen has performed particularly well
winning in places such as reunion
guadalupe french goanna and martinique
among many others and some of them
moreover by a wide margin what is
happening in overseas france and why
does it seem so different from the
european continent well visualpolitik
fans this is something we will talk
about in an upcoming video here on
visualpolitik so don't forget to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already done so also tell us what do you
think about the results of the french
elections what is your opinion of
emmanuel macron do you think france will
manage to get back on track leave us
your answer in the comments below and of
course if you found this video
interesting don't forget to hit the
little like button down there thanks
very much for watching and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you